kla bonjour tout le monde il ya quelques
jours j'ai sorti une vidéo qui s'appelle
les inventions imaginaire 2 alors je
suis hyper content parce que vous a
particulièrement plu sauf qu'au bout de
24 heures que tout est décidé de la
soumettre à une limite d'âge à cause
d'une scène où on entend un
jaillissement féminin pendant un acte
sexuel a pendant à peu près 3 secondes
voilà j'ai quand même fait une
réclamation auprès de youtube parce que
je trouvais que c'est exagéré un tout
petit peu et ils m'ont répondu quoi déjà
ils m'ont répondu on s'en bat les
couilles
voilà c'est assez étrange vu que j'avais
déjà fait dix mille fois à ce genre de
scènes de sexe sur youtube dans le passé
et j'avais jamais eu de problème à part
avec mon ex je trouve que nouveau
règlement youtube est quand même de plus
en plus strictes et ça c'est dommage
pour la liberté d'expression ne censurez
pas parce que je dis ça j'adore youtube
j'adore le règlement je les lui huit
fois en tout cas vu cette vidéo vous a
beaucoup plu et que j'en suis assez fier
je trouvais dommage qu'elle soit
inaccessible à plein de gens à cause
d'une restriction d'âge
du coup j'ai remonté une nouvelle
version sans cette scène pour que tout
le monde puisse la voir je vous laisse
donc apprécier cette nouvelle version de
la vidéo et nous on se revoit très
bientôt alors ques producteurs mais
bonjour voici la suite de ma vidéo sur
les inventions imaginaire c'est à dire
les inventions qui n'existe pas mais qui
pourtant serait très pratique au
quotidien comme par exemple une vitre
électrique anti mecs qui parlent trop
près du visage
moi je suis un très grand fan de martin
scorsese primo la réalisation secundo il
ya un plan séquence d'une minute 47 et
là tu vois que c'est un truc de malade
tu parles dans le micro la réalisateur
je te disais de scorsese un accélérateur
d'histoire chiante et donc non homologie
c'est la science des ans et c'est
vachement intéressant est ce que tu as à
gérer les petits poils sur les papillons
quand tu les caresses mais que c'est pas
mal
c'est comme ça que suis devenu
bouddhiste adacore super histoire c'est
cool et tu sais pourquoi j'ai levé
bouddhiste est ce que tu es déjà allé en
inde mais les temples y sont malnutris
ont un détecteur de l'origine d'une
mauvaise odeur
très pratique pour ces gens qui se lâche
sans pression en public l'odeur de foot
proviennent de cet homme car il faut un
anticipateur de postillons en fermant
furent une bd super chouette ça
s'appelle vaisseau super spéciale et un
moment il ya des défauts ils se tirent
dessus et ça fait une montre qui
permettrait de disparaître dans les
moments gênants salek parce que cette
digue de mer l'un c'est l'autre groupe
je suis guitariste je suis chanteur un
transformateur de films chiants en film
cool
bon c'est déjà ça s'appelle la bo ne
faut pas fumer beaucoup dans les moments
on ne sait pas trop quoi répondre à
quelqu'un une télécommande qui
permettrait d'avoir une seconde chance
de répartie norman le youtuber le mec le
+ vidéo on à la retraite monsieur
maintenant je peux rentrer est contraire
je fais enfin plein de vidéos je ne
bougeais retraite ouais un peu comme des
cheveux bon là j'ai une tête de south
park parce que j'ai complètement oublié
de filmer ce plan avec ma caméra et
ouais je suis je suis un peu con
l'invention suivante
ça serait un détecteur d'endroit où ça
gratte dans le dos alors grassement à
lahti tweet 16 et longitude 25 dit elle
une batterie d'iphone illimitée bon en
même temps ça existe ça s'appellera un
fils un wikipedia automatique dans le
cerveau qui l'a vu le parrain
ah oui tu dire ce film réalisé par
francis ford coppola produit par la cie
opara monde sorti le 15 mars 112 est
inspiré du roman éponyme de maria guzzo
bah ouais c'est ça tu en as pensé quoi
j'ai pas vu mais j'adorais un fouteur de
zone que t'as pas envie de regarder si
elles savaient que je vais flouter le
décolleté pour pas être tenté de le
regarder je vais passer pour un
gentleman
j'ai envie de me faire greffer des yeux
[ __ ] à la laci savais que je l'a
entièrement flouté que j'entends même
pas ce qu'ils disent est boloss à
adblock à blake pas marrante et tu
connais l'histoire de toto qui rendait
morts
c'est l'histoire des chinois d'un prêtre
et d'un boomerang dix camions tir sur
mon doigt ce serait vraiment pratique
pour les mecs pas marrant moi dont je
disais ouais je disais ouais nan en fait
c'est pas une bonne idée
un détecteur de potentiel de chance avec
les meufs alors elle 30% à 13 0% à ces
morts avec un mec à elle 90 % ok je me
lance est ce que je peux te déranger
mais fois que tu aimes les mêmes
chiffres ce que moi c'est marrant je me
suis dit que ce qu'on pourra les
comprennent à boire un verre et ai parlé
du fait qu'on aime les mêmes chips et ou
pas le stand est en fête et enfin ce qui
serait absolument génial ce serait une
invention qui lorsque vous aimez la
vidéo mais très directement à pouce en
l'air ça ça ce serait énorme
ou alors vous pouvez le faire à
l'ancienne
à bientôt
[Musique]